sorry but we do have our tournament
leader yes with Christopher Sophie
Sophie we are at a loss of words here in
the studio you're just playing brilliant
chess and the results keep on coming how
do you feel right now oh
I mean I'm doing better after like six
rounds than I've ever in this year than
I ever that I've ever done this
tournament like my entire life I think I
played like three times before my
highest score was like five out of nine
obviously and now you're six out of six
now what are you doing in this
tournament differently than your usual
preparation rest what's different that
makes you have such a high score and
play Such brilliant shots
um well I think the first thing I do
different is um I actually brought like
a physical board with me to help me prep
nice so
um I get like
I get them I get like the actual muscle
memory like I think it's it's working
very well this is my first time doing it
at an actual tournament by the way and
it definitely worked very well today
because you actually got a huge lead on
the clock in the opening phase you were
blitzing out your moves how did your
opening preparation go and when did it
finish uh finished after like
H4 and then my opponent played [ __ ]
before which like I
I looked at it in like a different
position but not that position and then
I was kind of on my own after Bishop to
F4 and without revealing too much what
was the main light here
um
Queen to F2 okay and then what was the
continuation here like H3 and then some
craziness in searing on the board
excellent so she played Bishop to F4
this was the surprise
how did you assess this position right
now like what were the nuances and and
the details that you were looking at
um well I thought it was like
probably equal at best for me honestly
yes and night weight when you play this
move H3 after quite uh some think now
after the move H3 what were the
candidate moves that you were looking at
um like here I was looking at I was
actually kind of more afraid of night
before for why actually right before and
this was the move that we were
considering as well
perhaps the uh the engine actually
really liked the move Knight to B4 at
least giving white a slight Edge but she
played the move G3 and then
you responded with this vicious
sacrifice Bishop takes E4
were you happy to see the move G3 and
allow you to do this yeah but then
um after F takes E4 I had a like Panic
moment I guess because after Knight G4 I
realized that Queen E2 was possible uh
which I didn't see in my calculations
but then even here like
I still have Rook takes C5 Queen takes
A6 and Rook takes C1 and I don't know
when I have no idea what's happening
um so I was actually really hoping like
why wouldn't play Queen E2
um but actually like the more I looked
at it the more I thought this is maybe
fine for me and it was the assessment
actually after looked ac1 is zero zero
zero uh but still wise position very
difficult because of the King right
despite the fact that you have a lot of
let's say material advantage as white
Still The King is very weak and in fact
it wasn't easy at all to play for white
right now now let's go back to the games
position she played the move Queen to C2
and after this it just felt like you're
taking over
did you know that you're better right
now
um I suspect it was like just a position
I didn't know if I was better or not I
just thought like this is an acceptable
position I can I could play it I guess
oh at this point it was just a dominant
situation and she played this weird move
A4
just uh not necessarily trapping her own
Knight but not bringing the Knight into
play as fast as she was supposed to
were you surprised by her decision I was
surprised by a four um I I understood it
though because like
I'm my plan is to play Brook C2 night
before Rook C3
um well that's one of my possible plans
um and then I there's like a few things
to calculate like with Knight takes A6
and I think I was playing like Queen A5
um
yeah and then the bird gets stranded
yeah on A6 yeah then I stranded but like
yeah I don't know I I was expecting like
Bishop takes H3 you know yeah
and she did not take that pawn on H3 and
or it was too late to pick it up after
that
the
it felt like after that the conversion
was quite smooth on your part Sophie a
big victory for you six out of six
tomorrow you're playing for a carwana do
you know what that is oh
oh I forgot I forgot what Carolina score
was but it was like the State field 2014
field Cup 2014 seeing through the cup
seven out of seven so tomorrow you have
a big chance to do that congratulations
and take a look and admire your line
score just simply brilliant
congratulations uh Sophie and we'll see
you tomorrow
our congratulations